[Music]
in life-saving app news oh lifesaver I
hope it's like an anti target app
because once I go on target oh that kind
of target yeah I want to finish it like
helps you it helps you just buy a toilet
paper or whatever you would in there
like I should ask you like what are you
here for and I'll say like toilet paper
and then as soon as I start clicking in
different categories it goes oh yeah
okay it blocks your vision you know what
I keep buying it at Target which is the
dumbest thing on earth I keep buying
like [ __ ] office supplies me - I'm
just gonna say staplers with ketchup
ketchup and garlic he buys all the
[ __ ] time we have so many ketchup
bottles like this okay I could get on
the office supplies more on the kitchen
you could never have too much ketchup or
gobbler thick cuz he's alright
submitted by heavy pulls our mother good
I love her II know a [ __ ] about your two
teens invented an app that will save
lives it's an app where you click it and
then you get random [ __ ] or dick
whatever you like wow I really think it
is people die of virginity if you had a
sex you will calm down exactly places
that have higher but [ __ ] causes of
food and women war have less war the
[ __ ] causes war where she doesn't share
if she [ __ ] both sides its World Peace
that's not what happened to the tro
share war they wanted little boys
buttholes so they stole the girls yeah
but she wasn't [ __ ] both sides if she
was shared [ __ ] the prince [ __ ]
the king and both sides had enough [ __ ]
there'd be no war it's cuz once i was
not getting enough [ __ ] or they weren't
getting enough food that just goes to
show you the power of women have over
the world hell yeah you guys control
everything so this app helps people get
[ __ ] okay yeah so that wasn't sarcasm
really believe it yeah if women wanted
to we can have world peace
sarcastic face but he's not being
sarcastic though okay
big dumb huh this is a [ __ ] echo
beanie anymore this 13 year old boy
named Charlie and his sister Hannah 16
years old 13 yeah do kids are learning
how to code right out the womb now like
they just come out not knowing HTML
that's probably an old coding now yeah
like what's the new one like Python it's
always some snake names like Cobra oh
yeah I understand your geek jokes I
don't know nerdy nerdy yeah so Hannah
last year she was diagnosed with a heart
condition called postural orthostatic a
hard word syndrome sounds like a very
sorry hi I understand that pulse
yeah pots which means that her her blood
pressure and her blood volume are
extremely low so she'll pass out or like
her blood pools in her legs and she sits
up her Sam I need some ginseng in her
life yeah so she got depressed because
of the she fell into a depression she
would like hold herself up in her room a
be sad to she started self-harming and
so one day one night her mom walked in
on her while she was cutting and she was
like why she held and all that that's an
Hannah thought like she wished she's
like I wish I could just press a button
send a notification out to my closest
friends and that it will notice that it
is a friend to the rescue yeah it says
hey Hannah Lucas is not okay come find
her and they'll give her the location
that's where she came up with this idea
so she clicks it then all her friends
would come to her and then so she won't
have like these like cutting thoughts
yeah like she could have like immediate
well people would come over there and
help her and be like are you what do you
need help or like here but here's more
nice no really I don't know you mean my
does that help depends you - David
really
David like for example why would they
create an app to help you cut yourself
not for example I wanted my ears pierced
so when I call my homie over he helped
me Pierce did he got a needle stuck to
my ear it's not a problem piercing right
now is that what self-harm is well that
you could use app for many uses not this
specifically for that area especially
we're talking about saving lives you
know what's crazy is someone invented
the self-cutting right and then
throughout time like everyone's doing
the same thing because if you enjoy pain
and self harming how come there's not
other things like oh she's been she
likes to stand on on thumbtacks or some
[ __ ] like you know like there's
different kinds of pain well because
cutting is a release it's like more of a
release thing so like standing yeah you
don't know what's better than that just
doing sprints
that's him self-harm right there that
[ __ ] is painful how happy if you want to
feel like your [ __ ] lungs are on fire
you do some sprints I'll try doing
Sprint's with your blood pools in your
legs that's really a sensible guy for
her she just has to try to stay awake I
shall be great isn't it but then they'll
have great circulation yeah she doesn't
have enough volume of blood so she
doesn't have enough like like diabetis
is it like diabetis no there's not no
blood volume diabetis isn't that the
sugar yes sugar yeah I know nothing
about the body it would be more like
what's that one where you don't stop
bleeding like once or maybe more like
AIDS anemia where you know it's one more
when you just get cut you just bleed to
death the platelet yeah and then there's
this is what happens whenever we try to
scientifically
I just want a doctor or scientist to
watch us and laugh at us every day
that's the reason why they watch us
we're entertaining for them also with
the blood clots Claudel itis hematoma
okay don't study you're just listing H
words hemorrhaging so when Hanna had all
this experience and she came up with the
idea and her and her brother started
working together because her brother
wanted to help her make make her dream a
reality what a good brother usually
thirty knows they're trying to ruin
their lives yep she's programming he's
probably going back and doing all of the
designing and stuff she has that typical
little brother smile he also has that
look that he does program on his spare
time
yeah but not okay app and so you just
click this button they'll notify the
people that you enter in the settings
now what the Michael Jackson songs about
okay okay and you're waiting for Hangul
okay it's Michael Jackson asked me are
you okay I think it's about a girl who
got taken advantage of it of from a guy
like a guy came and he he smooth-talked
her and then like he freaking like took
advantage of her and then left left her
emotion yeah I think it was like that
anyway so yeah this will be the
notification and I'll send the exact
location come help me where the person
is and then you can say like yes I can
help or no I can't help it must be nice
being smart or what best life and having
friends I feel like if I had this app I
wouldn't have friends to send it to when
I was a teenager you know your friends
as a team know you did I went to the
library at lunch I talked about this oh
you're one of those kids yeah I feel
sorry it's like a moderator on my board
I actually had friends but they were all
internet friends
they weren't really happy my god
how the [ __ ] are we friends right now
then Jesus just finding out faster I
want to unfriend you immediately I had
to learn social interaction okay it's so
easy to make friends in junior high or
high school all you have to do is go to
the section of the school that no one
hangs out up pull out a cigarette and
boom instant conversation you and my
five other kids that are smoking back
there maybe so I was actually friends
with the smoker kids and my friends all
got addicted to meth and went away so
that's why I was alone but that they're
a tight circle aren't they methods you
got you two are perfect this is a sad
corner over here easy for girls to make
friends however easy you just gotta
[ __ ] lower your shirt a little bit
yeah yeah twenty friends they're not
gonna be your lecture though they're not
the good friends yeah but you certainly
think girlfriends you idiots those are
guy friends at old friends are friends
the friends it doesn't matter friends
are friends with friends offense I've
had too many of those friends I got a
sad-ass childhood I just know how to
rewrite history we saw a throwback
picture you're laughing no but it's true
it's very true so anyway this app here
is six thousand people have downloaded
it already and OH ninety-nine a month so
they've been making some good oh it's
$2.99 a month yeah so is it $2.99 for
just the person that needs help or for
all the friends to I think what happens
if I if I if I if I'm guessing so if you
hit that button okay I don't know if I
stop talking did everyone 299 would call
it it would like said if you want to
accept this and cry for help text
message to those numbers that you would
put in or something maybe
but wouldn't you have they have to have
the apps in order for that they would
just receive a text message
oh you a support network is so important
though especially at this age to know
that people give a [ __ ] and they they
care and I feel like at this age -
everybody got problems and then some
people are making up problems because
they want attention yeah everyone's like
I wish I had some drama - [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'll do that Gary keep inventing new
like things like to have be my kids best
friend man
I should have be tired hell naw [ __ ] dad
I want to be my kids best friend don't
be telling me share the computer because
then you can't discipline them properly
busy what I think you're for a tie I
won't even have to discipline them
hopefully yeah well it depends on the
kids personality - well if my kid was
telling me a sad-ass story I'll just be
there like downer
[Laughter]
[Music]